welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm your
host paul it's like he's here in the room with
hey hey welcome to he's got this every
time he gets a little more piratey
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm your host
hearty mateys we're gonna watch the biggest wtf
questions from dr strange and the multiverse of
madness from paul hey hey peter paul paul leave
a like and subscribe to him he's struggling these
days and he could use the help awesome pity don't
worry paul after this reaction i'll send you uh
the thumb options i have and be like
which one do you think is the best
okay so doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness takes us on a two-hour trip through
alternate universes in the pursuit of getting
america chavez the f away from wonder i do
hide your kids because someone is gonna have to
raise them and i have to say that i absolutely
love the film i know it's very divisive with
people saying the plot is messy and that there's
some disappointing aspects in terms of things like
the illuminati but i had a complete blast sure
the big questions people have about the character
turns the plot holes and just general issues that
i see popping up this video is going to include
things like why wonders kids are the same even
though vision isn't there where the deadbeat bot
is why reed is the dumbest smartest man on earth
why gamora didn't cause an incursion and basically
as many questions as i can fit into a question
then please hit the green light and stop the video
if you enjoy our breakdown we love you in every
universe if you decide to like and subscribe and
with that other way oh thank you for clicking this
now let's get into doctor strange too okay so the
first big thing i want to discuss is why wonders
kids are the same in the eighth or eight universe
when she created them using magic in one division
surely they wouldn't be exactly the same because
the ones in the alternate reality were conceived
the old-fashioned way whereas the ones in the
hex just showed up out of nowhere like those
that post full cam spoiler clips on youtube
two days before the film now releases is pretty
confusing unless we take it that the westview
ones weren't who came first billy and tommy are
roughly about 10 years old i think and therefore
they would have had to have been alive for that
length of time if they're real one division only
happened recently in terms of the mcu timeline
and therefore they would have been created
after the real ones in the alternate universe
if we look at the a38 in general they're
far more advanced than the 616 timeline
and that's because the snap never happened and
therefore they had five years of developing things
ah good boy haven't even had him show up
in the 616 yet they most crucial five years
ahead but either way you slice it up there's
definitely a major time difference in terms
of how advanced they are right right right kids
are exactly the same is explained in the movies
in another reality yes wonder would have likely
dreamed about her alton itself met her kids that
way and then subconsciously brought them to life
that's a really great call really great call paul
paul with the great calls and then my thoughts
fall off the wall off the wall yeah that was
that was just really sad because um
of everything he said yeah absolutely
dreaming of the kids at any point that would
give her perfect subconscious material vision
yes in order to concoct the perfect replica
children i thought the kids are 10 years old
yes but this snap costs about like a five year
delay so they should be 15. it should be like
15 years old then by the time they get to this
universe some stuff is still not making any sense
paul yeah you're supposed to fix the movie paul
there was one theory that i think i did get right
about how she would have a connection in some way
to this other multiversal wanda and which allowed
her to conjure up the kids uh in our earth and
so yeah i would i went there mvp of the movie
me me we learned that in every other reality that
wonder is with their kids whereas in the 616 she
isn't so therefore she would have definitely
encountered them at several points and that
kind of segues me into the next point which is who
is the daddy whilst it would be easy to say vision
unfortunately and what does he do he exists in
the 838 universe and even if he does the events of
one division definitely didn't happen now we never
meet tony stark in this reality and therefore it's
unlikely that he actually exists there however we
do meet ultron bots which is why everyone on the
internet thought that tom cruise could show up
as superior iron man however i don't think that
these were created by the character and instead i
believe that reed richards was the person behind
them dubbed the smartest man if he really is that
then he probably created them without the flaws
and the main ultron wouldn't carry aspects of the
personality that tony has so reid likely figured
it all out and because ultron works he never tried
to make vision like what we saw in age of ultron
however even if the events of age of ultron did
somewhat happen and we got a version of vision his
time with wonder would have been a lot different
in the movie we learned that the illuminati killed
thanos on titan and with this happening it means
that he never would have gone to earth and ripped
the mind stone out of vision's head because this
didn't happen wonder would have never grieved him
created the hex and then become the scarlet witch
so ultron working his intended changes the course
of the mcu and instead i think that billion
tommy's dad are probably just some random guy
it's ultron is a nice message i suppose now well
i don't know i feel like it kind of contradicts
the rules a little bit there's not a tony stark
because the thing that made america chavez special
is the fact that she's the only one in all the
universes there is only one america shop chavez
where with these multiverses a big part of the
point is that we all exist just in different
you know universes and such so the tommy and
billy thing i think can be explained away like
you said with the snap but tony stark though i
think he would have to exist in another universe
and even with what if as they established was a
tony stark in every universe maybe that's it maybe
this one's just long since dead because apparently
they just want to kill him and everything
everyone is so yeah maybe we just died iron man
died off screen yeah dr strange too we're going
even further into a segway from this to talk
about why the illuminati don't care about wander
even though strange tries to desperately warn them
that she's coming to matrix their mouths because
those two they say in their reality strange is
the biggest threat after dreamwalking too much
supreme strange caused an incursion that killed
trillions of people because it wiped out an entire
reality this wonder isn't as big of a threat even
though we as the viewers know how dangerous she is
this also kind of ties into why they don't
really care and at one point captain marvel
even says that they can handle strange's little
witch now because all of the prior events like
age of ultron civil war infinity war end game
and one division never happened their wonder
is pretty de-powered it'd probably be about age
of ultron level which is why they think they're
fine just sending lots of ultron bots after her
as she was pretty scared of them in that film
in the comics the arrogance of hubris of the
illuminati always led to their downfall and they
just don't see wonder as a threat to them because
they're used to dealing with their one day they've
probably also looked into other realities and
have seen that in ninety nine point nine percent
of them that she's just a full-time yummy mummy
spends most of her days making her kids ice creams
they're just like met all those kids care about
his eyes this arrogance and underestimation of
her is why they weighed into the battle completely
unprepared and why reed even tells her about black
bolts power because they're pretty idiotic a lot
of fans have said that it's a wasted opportunity
to introduce them like this and i do kind of agree
with them on some level however the whole point of
them is to make us think that wanda has finally
met her match but she completely overpowers them
they are supposed to represent the best team on
one of the best earths the fact that wonder turns
them into pasta just elevates the threat wanda
pasta well wait a minute i've seen it twice now
and mordo when he has first seen and he's you
know doing you know another exposition dump
explaining and talk about dreamwalking and he
understands what the scarlet witch is and he's
part of the illuminati council you'd think that
he would take this situation incredibly serious
you had one job mortal he's the sorcerer on
the illuminati he's the guy who'd be the one
to take this seriously yeah and if they have the
darkhold in this universe then you think he would
especially have caused it elizabeth olsen kind of
referred to scarlet witch using this other wanda
as using the body like a bad car in a way so it
would decide that the limitations that she's not
in her body she's in a less oiled version of her
body so it's not capable of doing as much as our
universe as wanda could do you just imagine what
our universe is awana could do oh man if this
other wanda supposedly not as strong yeah it's
good that she wound up in this nerfed ass wanda
so if the scarlet witch came through on her own
then that would be an even nastier sequence of the
illuminati oh i know it should have been like you
are now secreting the insides of you through your
oh yeah it's gonna be like a cronenberg
movie i know a lot of chatter online is
about how we waited years for professor x and
also john krasinski to show up as mr fantastic
to throw them away seems pretty stupid
but i believe in my heart of hearts
that all these characters will be back in some
form or another disney of course acquired 20th
century fox so they'll likely be doing an
x-men movie soon we know that a fantastic
four is right around the corner captain
carter is confirmed to show up in season two
maria will probably be back in some form
or another in the marvels and black bolt
no yeah getting back in another earth so the
point of these characters justice for black
seconds people was the illuminati's inclusion
disappointing um it kind of depends if you're
more bothered about the cameos than what
they're supposed to represent but let me know
below exactly what you think about it okay find
out here which massively pulls from the comics
in the source material what happens is that two
worlds start to move towards each other on a
collision course that will destroy both of them
this is what the sacred worlds could look like
their fate or fight to the death until they
destroy the other reality which massively ties
into the secret wars event this will likely be the
big arc that's coming around the corner all right
i'll discover that if one enters another universe
through dreamwalking then it will start to create
a footprint there this will eventually cause
an incursion and that will destroy the reality
now this is very much why strange and christine
can't be together even though the pair both have
feelings for one another christine if they were
to live in a reality together it would eventually
pull either the 616 or 838 towards it which would
lead to a path of destruction so they say goodbye
at the end with strange saying he loves it in
every universe i'm not i'm not right you're crying
now the reason that america chavez and khloe it's
okay to cry because neither use the dark hole to
dreamwalk as we see claire cuts up in reality
into the dark dimension so she can enter an
axe at whatever universe she wants to this way we
also discover that america is the only version of
herself that exists in the entire multiverse urges
being her means there's no one for her to puppet
in another reality and therefore no incursions
will be caused okay so the incursions only happen
via the dream walking is that what i'm getting at
here is this is this what i'm trying to understand
i think so wouldn't wanda's involvement with
going to 838 and caused the incursion yeah you
would think unless it's also got to do with like
strange 616 being an 838 and maybe 616 is being
pulled toward him but it seems like dreamwalking
certainly exacerbates things but then why don't
the events of no way home cause incursions because
that was originally supposed to come after this
what about the events of when loki and sylvie
sometimes go to other universes you know
uh it's fine because he's a god they're gonna have
to come out with some kind of pamphlet that just
linearly explains multiverse through all these
different connected stories somehow asking the
questions has led to more questions but the
multiverse has become the x-men continuity
of the emcee there's actually another similarity
with the darkhold the book of ashanti and america
that we learn about in the film we discover that
the dark hold was created for the scarlet witch
and even see statues of tommy and billy at
the fortress later on catholic created this
in every universe to bring about the prophesized
scarlet witch and that is why there's a wonder and
darkhold in every reality however there's only one
book of ashanti because there's only one america
so there could be more scarlet witches when we see
the pages of the shanty open there's even a star
there like what america has now the reason gamora
doesn't expect an endgame is because technically
she's from the same reality as the one that died
the events of loki hadn't really transpired at
that point and therefore every time there was
a branch timeline created the tva shut it down
they also said in loki that end game was meant to
happen the way it did so they wouldn't ever wipe
out gamora she comes from 2014 in that reality and
therefore when her past self travels to the future
it doesn't create an incursion because she's still
from the 616. this is the same with steve rogers
who used the quantum tunnel to travel back through
time in the 616 reality and it was from here that
he created a branch timeline with peggy carter the
way light his use in the film also reflects at the
worlds which is why americas has different colors
in it because it's on a different color spectrum
whereas the 616 looks the same throughout now
a major criticism i've seen about the film is
that it's wonders in one division personally i
don't really see that as being true and in the
post-credits scene we left her on her own studying
the darkhold looking for her kids we pick up with
her studying the darkhold looking for her kids and
though it's getting compared to daenerys from game
of thrones i think there's actually way more here
wonder is also corrupted by the darkhold which
is why she's not really that reasonable anymore
and if you can accept that sinister strange was
turned evil by it then you can accept that wonder
was too i'm telling you you'll accept it remember
this is a book that prophesies the rise of the
skull witch and this it was written purely with
the intent of corrupting hair in order to turn her
into someone that would really entire multiverse
yeah i mean a lot of people do feel that way while
i think there's a middle chunk it doesn't feel
entirely disjointed to me to not fill in that
middle chunk ourselves because there's clearly a
time jump here from the post-credits scene of her
doing the darkhold which we know was not a no-no
you don't want to do darkhold then she hears her
children so she's been really experimenting with
it and now she really understands that there's a
possibility to somehow attain her children and the
dark holds evil i don't know i feel like the movie
laid it out pretty clearly i thought it made sense
i feel like there are scenes and supplemental
moments that you could show but i feel like the
progression makes sense coming out of one division
you know you could easily extrapolate that this is
where it might go and you can easily see the road
that led us here if you look back at that show
yeah i feel like the whole stinger of one
division is supposed to suggest a sinister turret
now who dying at the end could also explain
how we're getting the disney plus series i
get the house of harkness at the end of one
division wonder trapped agatha in an illusion
but with her apparent death at the film's
clothes we could see agatha breaking out of this
series the film very much brings the best argument
for rwanda death but we could definitely see her
back at some point good point also does this
with strange he very much grows as a character
throughout the film berlion christine says that
he always has to be the one holding the knife
which is echoed by her a38 counterpart however
come the end of the film he finally decides to
hand things over to america rather than taking
her power he no longer has to be the one holding
the knife and instead can now trust others he
did let tony stark sacrifice himself it's true
it's cold he wasn't holding the knife then that's
true he let tony hold the knife for thanos what a
generous guy so what's this whole thing about
you always have to do everything yourself with
us there's that one time if you'll recall i
got out of the way so the toad he could break
back so i don't know what you're talking about
right him fixing the watch in the final few scenes
also represents a lot of things for the character
the first film ended with strange staring at the
watch in the sanctorum accepting that he was
broken but still powering through it however
this film ends with him repairing it showing how
he's very much overcame the internal issues he
had over losing christine we're also introduced
to claire in the post credit scene who actually
ends up becoming his wife in the comics i guess
anyway another one opens and it's a great way
to take the character now lastly does wonder get
back on the lunch box nope and that's the video
we didn't cover this one as we already have a big
breakdown on it and that will be linked on screen
right now if you want to go and check it out
you're a good man paulie good man thank you paul
what i learned is that you can't have rachel
mcadams so instead he's getting an upgrade to
charlie's there and it's a downgrade depending on
your preferences so tell us in the comments below
is charlie's there and an upgrade for you or a
downgrade or right on the money a lateral move
guys subscribe to heavy spoilers he deserves to
be at a million subscribers sooner than later
hit that like button and yeah this slips
one more question but i answered a couple
of really big ones yeah you answered questions to
things i didn't really have a question about it
it does answer that question
providing a valuable service
questions you didn't even know
were there hey let's do a page
tyler hague tyler my man i want to go through
the multiverse to see all the different tylers
that are out there also versus tyler in one
universe tyler is the president of the united
states and he lets everyone have teddy bears boom
like wow you're the greatest president ever while
everyone demands healthcare benefits and then
in another universe tyler is a postal worker
constantly late to delivering mail and gets
fired from his job leading to him having
to room in his mother's basement and then
another universe tyler is a ufc cage fighter
who then faithfully gets injured rushing to the
hospital has a brain aneurysm it's not pleasant
and there's this other universe where tyler
he's just walking and then gets hit by a car
forever just in a loop it's like that meet joe
blackmon and another universe tyler is sleeping
then a guy comes in oh no drop kicks him in the
head brain aneurysm a fixed point and then at
another universe tyler's taking a shower then
his skin melts oh no the water becoming too hot
there's nothing happening hot water universe
i'm sorry for the events but in our universe
you get to live and not get ostracized
by the united states citizens of america
absolutely not get accepted that's right
dude so thank you for being you tyler hey